the return of what you all love
Dah da da da da medical abbreviations
we start with an easy what does it mean AG
hmm a general anesthesia
in the same category what does ALR mean
hmm ALR I think it is a loco-regional anesthesia
in your transmissions you will often see written ATCD and it means
this is your patient's history
you will also find all the famous 3 t's that mean
these are your patient's treatments
you will also be able to see written in your transmissions and this means
it's a public highway accident
you may also see 3 CG written
it means
It means that your patient has been transfused with 3 globular nerves
and therefore when you transfuse your patient you will often see written RAI
it means
it is an irregular agglutination search and it must be negative
by the way,
if you are interested
we can make you a special video course on everything that is
so the rai if they are positive negative all that
tell me in comments if you are interested